♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
And we are the
Gun Trace Task Force.
No matter what you're doing
out there in those streets...
Jackpot, motherfuckers!
Woo!
...your word prevails.
GEORGE PELECANOS:
The story of We Own this City
is about one of
the most corrupt squads
in policing history.
-OFFICER: Police!
-(OFFICERS YELLING)
OFFICER: Police.
Get on the ground.
REINALDO MARCUS GREEN:
This is not just make-believe.
Every single story
in this series
was based on some
real life, true event.
We Own This City is a book
by Justin Fenton.
JUSTIN FENTON: Yeah,
I've been a crime reporter
in Baltimore since 2008.
So I had a front row seat
to all these stories.
D. WATKINS:
Back when I was coming up,
police officers used to
pull up on a crowd of people.
Jumped out of the car,
and they made all of us
lie down face first
on the concrete.
They all go.
Then when I become a journalist,
I felt compelled
to tell their stories,
to tell my story,
to talk about
what we've been going through.
DAVID SIMON: There's something
really gratifying about
working off the real.
But then, it carries this...
concomitant responsibility.
In the writer's room,
we had to argue out:
What is it fair to say,
what is it not fair to say?
PELECANOS:
The pandemic put us all
in a position where
we actually could take
a year and a half
to write this thing.
GREEN: George Pelecanos
and David Simon,
their research
is second to none.
In the writer's room,
there was court documents
and all types of things
stacked up
to the ceiling, right?
PELECANOS: We tried to film
mostly in the locations
where the incidents occurred.
-Driver, show me your hands.
-Hands! Show me your hands!
-Get out of the fucking car!
-Get out of the car!
GREEN: You know where
the shellings were placed,
exactly the cross streets,
the type of car,
the make, the vehicle,
who was on the streets.
(TIRES SQUEAL)
It feels authentic
because it is.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
I'm Nicole Steele
with the Department of Justice.
Nicole Steele is one of
the few people in the show
who's not based on
somebody who's real.
SIMON: Nicole Steele
is a composite, really,
of a number of investigators
with the civil rights division.
We hold hands,
we twist arms.
WANMI MOSAKU:
Ray and David and George,
we all talked about
how Nicole's character
almost feels like the audience.
She's watching this
melee of madness
and asking, "Why?"
There was a lot of discussion
in the writer's room
about the limits
of the federal government's
consent decrees,
given the continuing
war against drugs.
And through
Nicole Steele's character,
we get to see
her struggling with that.
What happens if the police
don't want to change?
SIMON: We really wanted
to pay attention
not only to what was happening
to the Gun Trace Task Force,
but what was happening
to the world around them.
PROTESTERS: (CHANTING)
No justice, no peace!
The conversation is bigger
than a few bad apples.
(YELLING)
The conversation should be
about a system
that rewards officers
for being the bad apples.
I think Baltimore
is a microcosm
for what's happening
all over the country.
-DIRECTOR: And action.
-WAYNE JENKINS: On the ground.
Get down on the ground.
Hey, man! That's some
great fucking police work, dog!
It's yours. You earned it.
(POLICE RADIO CHATTER)